[Musique]
chérie hier encore d'audience pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
les jours est un phénomène annales
là
hélas
[Musique]
c'est parti
merde
mais mr gay chine très belle chance en
tout cas une belle anecdote vous
connaissez pas marqué ce mois çi dans
mary à tout prix
ah oui exceptionnel alors il n'y a pas
eu de soucis d'avignon la ligne en était
une fois dans l'année mais écoutez
j'essaie de faire des chroniques que
tous les soirs avec un pakistanais qui
est formidable très bien pakistani
t'emmerde allait valoir
ok je m'appelle minutes tu peux
présenter un film c'est que j'aimerais
ça s'appelait pas encore le show 6r nos
récentes à conquête tu prendra ma place
pour le non un tueur est à tapas tu
restes au siège 2 et tu raques les
dégâts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saleh
[Applaudissements]
et
on
toujours là
saad
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire je veux dire l'auteur
je vais le dire une bonne fois pour
toutes
e je vous le dis non mais je vous le dis
c'est ça suffit de se frotter à bord
mais ça suffit c'est devenu une habitude
tout le monde
tout le monde se frottent je ne suis pas
un tampon gex alors allez-y raymond
mercier jean-michel
[Musique]
chez moi les coins sauvages
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
genève a dîné avec des chirurgiens qui
m'ont demandé de vous demander si vous
aviez fait cet été une opération de
chirurgie esthétique
alors il ya plein de gens qui demandent
je n'ai jamais rien fait j'ai jamais
regardé joue mes deux frères donc très
hâte parce qu'il vendait ce que j'ai
fait j'ai juste fait rétrécir un truc
généreuse à quoi le nez j'ai dit données
et ya géraldine maillet a dit il en
reste encore donc il est plus petit que
votre bouche tabac l'afo son père fouras
google c'est la seule qui ont leur poids
moyens
[Applaudissements]
son mari la femme sexy on avait
complètement aux hôtes à la vie voilà de
quelqu'un qui découvre la vie mais
quelqu'un qui est le plus frais ici
c'est vrai vous désirez vous êtes comme
un ananas
ouais c'est vrai vraiment on vous ouvre
on sait pas ce qu'on va trouver à les
hommes c'est comme à l'adresse sais pas
s'il va être dur et l'ananas il est tout
noir cataracte est dégoûté bas lui c'est
pareil si tu pas acquis et des boîtes
youtube mais c'était une manière de
parler et on côté vraiment extérieur ton
oeil extérieur et qui apporte à
l'émission donc si vous êtes élu on n'en
peut plus aller kelly et on a quoi pour
qui c'est sur moi là bas bien sûr que
c'est sûr vous relance la vidéo ben
imani allons-y
c'est ma nouvelle tête est alors nous
l'eau
[Musique]
lui envoyer des fleurs etc donc ils ont
essayé de retrouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]